this is a good jumping off point because
i'm curious you know we're old guys now
i'm 50 i don't know how old you are brad
i think you're a couple years older than
me
jason i'm the same damn age we're both
50 both born and 19
i just turned 50 yeah okay so then i'm
older than 250 on november 28th so
we're gen xers right and um you know
there's a generation of journals who are
coming up who are very anti-capitalism
anti-you know that they've got concerns
about wealth despair they've got
concerns about the unions and workers
and workers rights
i have to say when when we look at
um what amazon has contributed
to society
it's hard for me to look at it and say
this has not been amazing and
extraordinary
for society the fact is
the best idea of the last 20 years or 30
years
by the scorecard the scorecard being you
know consumers wanting to consume
something and engage with it as a
product
was the everything story getting
anything you want within originally i
guess two days getting anything you
wanted then getting within two days and
then one day and now who knows maybe
we'll get it into an hour
that idea was the greatest idea
of the past 30 ideas
voted on by consumers dollars right i
mean we both agree on that
i can't think of any idea that consumers
voted more for
and now i don't know if you saw today or
maybe was just yesterday the news broke
that they're going to cover people's uh
bachelor's degrees
right they pay double minimum wage the
federal minimum wage they didn't have to
be
you know harangued into doing that they
just did it they're fighting to get
workers there and you hear you know
elizabeth warren and aoc attacking
you know and trying to protect the
workers of amazon i don't hear the
workers of amazon complaining at all and
then you had that new york times story
where they said oh all these people had
the worst possible traumatic ptsd
experience at amazon but you know more
amazon workers and
amazon executives than anybody in terms
of interviewing i don't think there's a
single person on the planet outside of
amazon's hr department who has
interviewed more
executives you
know how fiercely loyal and how much
they love jeff and the company so what
is the how do you look at it just as a
chronicler of this putting aside your
hat at bloomberg as a chronicler
do you look at amazon as good for
society and good to its workers
executives down to the people working in
the factories right i i you know i would
not have written two books and devoted a
large portion of the last decade of my
life in my 40s yeah
to to crawl including this company if i
just wanted to kick it in the knees if i
thought it was a nefarious uh presence
in society i'm uh amazon prime member
i'm elec an alexa owner i watch the
movies and the tv shows so you know i'm
i'm i'm a customer at the same time i
think both things are true it's okay an
amazing company um but you know like a
lot of tech companies right it's grown
it's created a platform um and
globalized and moved at a speed and
left a trail of destruction and and had
to account and is accounting now you
know for some of the mistakes it's made
i mean what is the transit
yeah right it's it's well there's a
number of different dimensions i mean
one it's um you know creating a
globalized marketplace and reducing the
friction creating a self-service system
for sellers around the world reducing
all friction to selling and now spending
billions of dollars to fight
counterfeits and fraud and ensure that
the items are safe right there's there's
i have a chapter on that there's you
know to okay
just to unpack that for a second
unintended consequence of when you take
all friction out of people selling
specifically the third party
sellers where they let anybody sell on
their platform which is i think you
would agree like an incredible decision
they made um
because because alibaba and and then a
startup called wish were were doing that
and it was uh it was a disruption and
they had to move move quickly and and
and yeah there were consequences to that
and the the consequence is hey somebody
who's working at a factory who made this
incredible startups product might at
night run the factory for somebody else
make a
knockoff version in amazon
let's be honest probably turned a blind
eye to it for a while is that what you
would discover
or added a lithium-ion battery that
exploded into flames when you plugged it
in okay um
all sorts of examples yeah but that's
one dimension i think the labor thing
you know you're right in that the
preponderance of amazon employees are
not complaining vociferously you know
they're happy to work there um they're
having productive careers they're having
their education paid for but we can't
ignore a vocal
subset of employees um you know some who
get ill who develop ergonomic disorders
at work
pregnant employees who it's well
documented have been sort of mistreated
by a company that historically is so
focused on meeting its promises to
customers getting efficient building at
rapid speed now thousands of fulfillment
centers around the world you know there
is room for improvement and amazon has
acknowledged that it's trying to get
ahead of it in part because it's a very
competitive labor market
hey everybody i thought i would have
christina cassiopo on this weekend
startups to tell you about vanta vanta
of course has been sponsoring the pod
and had a great reaction and we're going
to talk today just a little bit about
what sock 2 compliance is and why it's
so important for sas products welcome to
the pod christina thank you so much for
having me how long does this typically
take
and what does it cost yeah so in the uh
you know prior world if you didn't use
software like fanta often companies
would take about a year on the project
to figure out what they needed to do get
everything in order work with the
auditor get the auditor what they needed
to get their report and they probably
spent 20 000 on the low end kind of can
go up to hundreds of thousands of
dollars depending on how large you are
you figured out a way at vanta to do
this um quicker better and cheaper so
what is the secret and how can people
use the product yeah absolutely so
secret is sort of like a lot of things
you turn you turn a lot of this into
software so you
write a standardized set of checks that
a company needs to do you base them on
good security principles and then you
just monitor and alert all of those
things so the company gets a dashboard
they always know where they are they're
not you know mucking around in
spreadsheets and the auditor gets just
really detailed data so they can be sure
that what the company says they're doing
is actually happening all right
fantastic well thanks so much for coming
on and telling the audience why you
should get your sock 2 when you should
get it and how you should do it and
you've been very nice to our audience
giving them a thousand dollars off which
is a really significant and generous
offer go to vanta.com twist
v-a-n-t-a dot com slash twist to get a
thousand dollars off your sock too
thanks christina appreciate it thank you
so much